Hey guys, Pete here. Just finished
watching the Watchmen season finale, and
wow. I really enjoyed it. this will be a
top moments recap and reaction sort of
thing. I've only watched it once at this
point. so, it's not going to be a deep
dive, but the hype is real and I wanted
to talk about it. later this week I will
put out some more videos to take a
closer look. this video will contain
spoilers for the first season of
Watchmen on HBO. if you haven't watched
the season finale yet this video is not
for you. please watch that and then come
back just hit the subscribe button
before you leave. we have to start at the
ending because that is the elephant in
the room and not that elephant, that
elephant was apparently just a host to
help clear out Angela's brain after
taking hooded Justices in nostalgia, I'm
talking about Angela eating the egg and
us not getting to see what happens when
she attempts to walk on water. if you're
anything like me you were sitting there
on the edge of your seat. I half expected
her to fall into the water and not be
able to walk on it, but in the end we
don't find out what happens. I'll talk
about it as an ending more later when I
get into Will Reeves' story and the
conclusion of Jon Osterman and Angela's
story. before that though I will say that
Damon Lindelof the series creator spoke
with Deadline and they asked him
straight out if this was going to be the
end of the series. he says he doesn't
know, that's the answer. and to quote, "All
I can say is I've consistently believed
and still believe that these nine
episodes are a complete story with a
beginning, middle,and end. I have to
acknowledge that not everyone's going to
see it that way, and I definitely don't
dispute any opinion that's sort of like
there should be more. I just don't feel
compelled to continue the story without
a reason to do so. that reason should be
a creative reason, idea-driven, and I
don't have any ideas for subsequent
seasons of Watchmen currently." he goes on
to say where I'll paraphrase that
every show's ending if it doesn't have
the destruction of creation could
potentially continue. if anyone's still
alive the world could be continuing so
we'll leave that discussion there for
now and I'll get into my favorite
moments of this episode. first on that
list is the Ozymandias' Lady Trieu
parentage reveal. I loved how her mother
stole his seed and I loved how Alexander
the Great was staring down as
she did the inseminating there in his
office. overall I think this makes sense,
it was pretty good.
as soon as I saw the camera pull back
and the cameraman was Vietnamese I was
sure that that was how things were gonna
go and I really enjoyed that call back
to Karnak from the original comic book. I
really enjoyed their introductions. I
really enjoyed the way that they got to
know each other her using the idea that
no one gives him credit for the
wonderful work he did for saving the
world. her explaining her plan to take
Dr. Manhattan's power set the stage. him
challenging her to do it on her own
without his help. and of course him
saying that he will never call her
daughter - which leads us right into the
next one and the next big moment is the
escape from Europa. we find out that it
was save me daughter that he spelled
out with the Crookshank's and Phillips's
corpses. she comes through sends him an
escape craft, and this whole sequence was
fantastic. we find out that he created
the game warden persona had him wear a
mask because masks make men cruel and he
did it all to have a worthy adversary. the
look on his face when he's walking away,
him catching the bullet and having that
whole thing set up just to satisfy his
own ego. if you didn't read the comics he
catches a bullet from Laurie in the
actual end of the comics which this
is a callback to that so the whole
conclusion of this story is pretty
fantastic and that we see is hubris the
way that he looks so victorious here we
know that's probably gonna be a setup.
can't help but feel terrible for the
Crookshanks and the Phillips especially
knowing that their god is going to be
destroyed later on as a complete
sidetrack I'd like to think that Dr.
Manhattan took Angela there for their
first date, the one that he was asking
her for dinner you know, when they
met in Saigon. so at least we can keep in
the back of our mind that if she is the
new Manhattan and she can teleport all
around that she knows about the
wonderful Crookshanks is and Phillips
on Europa and will go to visit them. but
otherwise you know they're just there
and Adrian didn't do anything except
use them as a way to get off of
there which is pretty sad in the end.
although I really enjoyed the
Crookshanks putting on the headband
right before he goes into the craft and
by this point we all figured out that he
was probably going to be turned into a
statue and that was
fun to see that get paid off. the next big
moment was Looking Glass' return. we
knew he would show back up and he did I
liked how they paired him up with Laurie
and kept those two characters together
this pays off in a big way later when
they're in Karnak because I kept
thinking he was gonna shoot Adrian Veidt
in the face at any moment to get revenge
for the squid attack and all the
problems that that caused him in his
life we'll come back to that in a second
because right after Looking Glass shows
up Dr. Manhattan is teleported in and
that leads us into the next big moment
which is Senator Keene's big speech now
the speech is fantastic on so many
levels we see that his father's been
brought in his father remember is the
one that got masked vigilantes outlawed
back in the 70s we hear that their
problem is based on the fact that a
liberal president has been in charge and
that's caused so many problems for the
people who used to be in power and like
I said this really is a fantastic speech
he says first they took our guns and
then they made us say we were sorry and
he could say something like sorry for
the alleged sins of people that died
generations before we were born sorry
for the color of our skin and not see
the irony in what they're trying to do
here it's perfect so we find out what
their gripe is which isn't surprising we
find out how they got the plan to get
Dr. Manhattan we found out that he chose
to wear the government-issued underwear
that Dr. Manhattan wears in the comic
for the big event
and he tells Angela when she arrives
that he's gonna squeeze her man down
like a grape and drink him up which is
great because when we see him later he
looks like the one who's been squeezed
as a grape speaking of Cyclops the next
big moment is them getting lasered by
Lady Trieu this was completely satisfying
to watch and there's not too much to say
about it except for way to go Lady Trieu
at least you did something good before
your story ended the next moment would
be Ozy saving the world again dr.
Manhattan is able to use the Keene-goo to
teleport them back to Karnak. Ozymandias
gets a plan to freeze the squid and
start a squid fall over Tulsa that will
be like a Gatling gun going off I really
enjoyed how he said it takes
one to no one after he called his own
daughter a narcissist I certainly took
note when he corrected Looking Glass
saying I saved humanity you ignorant
hayseed and like I said the whole time
they were there I just kept wondering if
he was gonna do something that was gonna
cause Looking Glass to shoot him in the
face everything about his plan in the
way that it was implemented was great
especially Lady Trieu looking through the
hole in her hand when the first squid
hits her and the whole scene at karnak
set up the next moment which is Laurie's
conclusion and the arrest of Adrian
Veidt I wondered about this in the
questions video I made right before the
finale came out if what he did will get
out there this doesn't answer that
question but we do know that they took
him prisoner in Archie the original owl
ship which was awesome that they had
that there at Karnak and they took him
into custody this is a pretty good riff
on the comics ending because it's
similar to Rorschach sending his journal
out we don't know what effect that's
gonna have to the lasting peace after
things settled down we know Lady
Trieu's been defeated
we know that Jon Osterman Dr. Manhattan
as such has been destroyed but when the
dust settles were really not sure
exactly how things will play out going
forward and that part of the ending at
least feels like a Watchmen ending the
next big moment was the conclusion to
Will's story of course like I said we saw
Cyclops top brass get lasered they won't
be causing any problems any time soon
that was the deal that will made he
would give up Dr. Manhattan of Lady Trieu
would take care of Cyclops the whole
idea of nothing ever ends comes to mind
here killing the leaders of Cyclops
doesn't end white supremacy it doesn't
end racial and justice in the same way
that dropping a squid on New York ended
nuclear war at least at that moment it
didn't erase the fact that people have
that inside of them that they war with
each other and that sooner or later
there would be something to take the
nuclear threats place and that's why dr.
Manhattan told Adrian Veidt nothing ever
ends so killing these guys didn't end
racism but it is nice to see her to
justice get justice as far as Cyclops is
concerned and this is a little bit more
palatable since three million people who
didn't have to die just the ones that
were in that room and them dying will be
a blow to the power structure the
set up inside their organizations and to
bring it all full circle it happened in
Greenwood and it happened where the
Tulsa race Massacre happened that will
witnessed as a boy the conversation
between will and Angela was fantastic
filling us in on how he got there
him knowing that she had the pills and
took them so she understands how he
became hooded justice and what he went
through there's a really nice touch here
where he asked her how she felt when she
put on the hood how it made him feel and
she said angry and he said yeah that's
right except for that it was really fear
and hurt he shows sympathy for her and
losing dr. Manhattan and we learned that
it was dr. Manhattan's plan all along
and I really liked how he said based on
what he could do he could have done more
he said he was a good man but he could
have done more and that leads into the
final big moment which is Jon Osterman
and and the conclusion of the Dr.
Manhattan Calhattan and Angela's love
story we learned that it was his plan he
knew he was gonna die in the moments
just before he breaks apart there's a
fantastic moment where Angela's trying
to get him to fight trying to get him to
stay she asked him where he's at and he
says I'm in every moment we were
together all at once I love you Angela
and damn just damn it was incredible
what a way to go out and of course we go
back to the house and after talking with
will Angela discovers the egg we see her
eat the egg we don't know if she got all
of his powers some of his powers we
don't know what happened and it's a
cliffhanger in a way but it actually
isn't the kind of cliffhanger that needs
to be answered the big threat has been
stopped
Lady Trieu wasn't able to turn herself
into a god Ozymandias is in custody and
according to Peteypedia agent Dale Petey has
been fired from the FBI he's no longer
an agent but he's staying behind in
Tulsa to try to get to the bottom of
what really happened so we don't know
what's gonna happen with president
Redford he would be complicit in
covering up adrian veidt's plan that
could mean that things will continue the
way they're going Adrian will never have
to be held accountable for what he did
but Angela may be dr. Manhattan agent Petey
who is
definitely Lubeman might be out there in
the world Dan Dreiberg who is Nite Owl
II is still in federal custody he knows
the truth
Laurie Blake still out there and perhaps
has a great new relationship with mirror
guy
aka Looking Glass but it has come to an
end the main story in Tulsa for right
now has concluded the story of dr.
Manhattan being created in Gila flats
when Jon Osterman was tore apart at the
atomic level and then reassembled
himself to become a blue god there's an
ending to that and I hope that there's
more Watchmen to come but we'll wait and
see how that goes I'm gonna leave the
video there let me know in the comments
what your favorite moments were I'm
gonna go listen to the official podcast
and read all the interviews and then
I'll probably come back with a deep dive
in the next couple of days I enjoyed
this finale it answered most of the
questions I wanted answered I think that
a lot of people probably liked it but
there will be a lot of people who don't
so let me know what you think what would
you have liked to seem different how are
you feeling about a season two now and
what do you think happened when Angela
put her foot on top of that water in the
pool it was important for later please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already thanks for watching guys thanks
for watching watchmen with me this
season I'll talk to you soon